Yes hello! Let's deploy an open source library.
My name is Eunjae Lee
I was born in Korea and grew up there
I moved to Singapore at the end of 2016
And in 2019, I moved to France and I've been living here ever since.
In France, I work for a company called Algolia.
Algolia is a cloud service provider that provides search functionality.
They provide a full suite of toolkits for developers
In Algolia
The brief description is
The backend such as infrastructure, engines, databases, etc.
On top of that is the REST API
There are APIs in charge of indexing or search functions, for example.
API clients are provided on top of that REST API.
PHP, Ruby, JavaScript, Python, Kotlin, .NET
Java, Golang, Scala, iOS, are Android
are some of the languages in which you can use the API client.
And on top of the JavaScript API client, we developed something called Instant Search
You can think of it as a kind of JavaScript component library.
The user can directly call the search API using the API client.
Instead of displaying the results directly,
you just have to attach the components that we provide for the website or app to be complete.
For example, there are components for
a search bar, filter, pagination, and so on.
So, I'm working on this JavaScript component library
called Instant Search.
I work on its team.
So this team develops the InstantSearch.js vanilla JS library, but
we are developing Instant Search in 4 flavors total, including React, Vue, and Angular.
And I am developing and maintaining many other libraries.
Coding seems to be loved by everyone.
I don't think there are many people listening to the presentation that hate coding.
They code at work
Also, many people will like to do side projects at home after work and on weekends.
And testing and debugging are pretty popular.
In particular, the test was done with TDD or other ways
There are people who are very passionate about this topic
And rather than saying that I just like debugging itself, its the feeling when a bug is removed
There are such joys, so it seems that many people like testing and debugging.
But is there anyone who likes deploying?
I Like deploying
Well I love deployment. I will deploy it on the weekend.
I will deploy on Friday evening. I don’t think I’ve heard anything like this.
Especially when it comes to deploying libraries, it seems to get worse.
First, before talking about libraries,
let’s talk a little bit about app deployment.
Many people now use CI/CD services to deploy apps.
Just to name a few, we have
Netlify, Vercel, Bamboo Jenkins, etc.--there are many CI/CD services.
Since those people use a lot of these tools to deploy,
But I think that deploying libraries in particular is a little less enjoyable.
There are many reasons, but I'll just give you a few reasons I can think of.
First, we're worried about bugs
Once deployed, the bug is also deployed.
Unlike apps, in the case of libraries,
even if you deploy a fix
the user has to update the library again.
So it takes one more steps than an app, so I think we're more concerned about bugs.
But now I can't help you with that part.
Concerns about bugs can be solved only if you don't have a bug
To ensure that, you have to write good code
Also, to catch errors, you have to write good test cases,
so that, even if something goes wrong, we can find the error.
You need to have a system that monitors certain errors and exceptions.
But that is completely outside the scope of my presentation
Let's say that I can't help you with that, and let's ignore it.
After that, I think we worry a lot about mistakes
There are various mistakes, such as using the wrong version of NodeJS.
Though there are many Node version managers,
sometimes when we go back and forth between several projects,
These kinds of problems definitelyexists.
And what we often forget is that
if you forget to `git pull`
it would be a fatal mistake to deploy the old version.
Or you may be deploying with the command `npm publish`
but if you forget the argument of `--tag beta` and deploy it
It would be a big mistake. You'd be deploying it as a stable version rather than the beta.
And I don't know how everyone feels about this folder called `node_modules`.
We don't think we did anything wrong, but problems arise.
That happened a few times for me, so I'd delete this folder and call `npm install`
or `yarn install` again.
Another problem is the wait.
If you run lint, unit tests, and even end-to-end tests, you have to wait until everything finishes
This screen shows an end-to-end test for Instant Search JS
In fact, for an end-to-end test
4min 30sec can be seen as not much, pretty short.
However, though you might think that 4min 30sec is not long,
while waiting, even just 5 to 10 seconds,
at least in my case I lose my patience and immediately hit command + tab
and go to Twitter, scroll for about 10 to 15 minutes before I remember I was running a test
and when I check back, the test would already be over. This happens often.
In the process of switching between contexts
time and energy are lost
Another way to wait
Now it takes time to run lint or tests to deploy from your base branch.
But during that time we might want to move to another branch
and work on that branch, but that's risky.
It's safe to just leave that folder in its base branch
Because there is a risk of something going wrong, so we try not to touch it
and just wait and wait.
So now let's take a look at
what kind of process we usually go through when deploying a library.
The versions are named using the convenstion semver, which stands for semantic version.
The first number is the major, then the minor, the patch, and so on.
When deploying a library, it's important to decide what the next version will be, according to the convention.
Then there is an idea called Conventional Commit.
There is a website called Conventional Commit.
You can visit the website to get more details but for example, there could be a commit message like this.
The prefix 'fix' means that this commit fixes something.
The part after the colon describes the actual commit.
Writing 'fix(compiler)' defines the compile as the scope of the fix.
So to repeat, this commit is a commit that fixes something
in the compiler. It's saying the fix is related to the compiler.
So that's how you parse the version name.
It says 'chore', meaning this commit was in part of some kind of a chore.
It would be a commit that doesn't have a big impact on the version
You can consider something like documentation update, which may not affect the update much.
Another is 'feat', indicating a new feature. You can specify the scope likewise.
And in the case of this commit message, 'BREAKING CAHNGE' is entered in capital letters.
This commit with 'BREAKING CHANGE' is literally
the convention saying there's a breaking change, so the update had better be a major version update.
So all commit messages starting with prefixes like fix, chore, docs, reactor, test, etc.
These are commits that require patch updates.
In addition, in case a new 'feat' function is added, but backward compatibility is maintained,
then it is a minor update
And if the BREAKING CHANGE is included in a commit message, this will be a major update.
So this Conventional Commit message was influenced by the Angular team and has been developed.
A lot of libraries are using it now
Vue.js, WebPack, Angular, Nuxt., Gatsby, jest
It is used by many open source libraries and also by many companies.
Now lets look at the conventional changelog.
If you have seen a changelog file like this, you can almost always use a tool called Conventional Changelog
You can see it as a generated file
Shall we look at what the Conventional Changelog does?
Now the most recent release was version 0.15.0
And on top of that, the commits are newly released commits.
Then, the docs commit message does not affect the version
They don't enter the changelog.
Likewise, these chores commit messages are ignored by the conventional changelog.
So in the end, only the three commit message are included in the changelog.
You can see the result here
This fix goes into the bug fix section like this
This goes in like this
Also, this feature goes into a section called features
As you can see, the scope on error was included in bold
And because new features were added, minor updates were made.
Another thing to pay attention to when deploying the library is the argument '--tag'
In some cases, it can be deployd by tagging alpha,beta,dev,canary,rc, etc.
In fact, I once forgot to deploy as a beta and released as a stable version.
It's important to watch out, but easy to overlook.
Now let's see how the Instant Search team do a release.
The repository has a file called src/scripts/publish.js
I ran this when deploying
Then, when you run this, what the script does is makes sure that the working folder is cleaned and everything is committed.
And we see if there is anything we're working on that needs to be committed
After that, it updates the version in package.json.
Update the changelog and 'git commit' those changes
Run 'run test', build and 'npm publish'
and add --tag beta as necessary.
And by doing 'git tag', it creates a new version tag and pushes it.
All of the processes I've been describing are in this script.
So I just ran it as it is, so there was no problem
But, as I mentioned, the repository has a file src/scripts/publish.js
This is the file in the InstantSearch.js repository.
But in fact, the same file exists in the React repository
and it exsists in Vue,
and in Angular as well.
But it's all a little different
I think that was one of the very difficult points to manage
Anyway, I have this script, but I can still make mistakes for the reasons I listed earlier.
That’s why I’m still nervous and every time I deploy
I once called a colleague to sit in front of my computer to deploy together.
And you still have to wait for those tests to succeed
If so, what can we do?
I'll give you two solutions.
First, there is a tool called 'np'
I don’t know how to pronounce the name of this persion
They're very famous
They've been making a lot of active open source libraries and software
This np is literally a better version of the npm publish tool.
If you run this, it cleans up and
installs dependencies, runs tests
bumps the version, publishes the package, and pushes the tag.
It's almost the same as the script I had.
But now one problem is when trying to deploy
it asks for the next version like this
They are leaving the user to choose the next version.
And another problem with this is that you have to wait until it's all over
An alternative is sementic-release, another popular tool.
It's titled a "fully automated version managment and package publishing tool".
So as you can see
When you run this, it goes through steps like Verify Conditions, Get last release, Analyze commit,
Verify release, Generate notes, Create git tag, prepare, publish, notify
You can think of it as a slightly beefier version of what we talked about earlier.
It's a good tool, and it's being used a lot.
But the fact that it was fully automated rubbed me the wrong way
because there's no room for me to intervene.
So I wanted to balance something between completely manual and completely automatic.
To do that, I thought I will need a different process.
I thought it would require a different process than what I was doing
So I was thinking
and divided the process into three steps
The first is Prepare, the second is the Review, and the third is the Trigger.
Let's look at them one by one
'Prepare' gets the next version.
The next version can now be easily obtained because the commit message has a convention.
Then it checks out to a temporary branch.
For example, 'git checkout -b releases/v1.2.3' checkout to a temporary branch like this
It updates the version of package.json in that branch.
And the changelog is also updated.
It commits that change and makes a pull request
So this was the first part.
The second part is simple.
Just review the pull request.
When reviewing a pull request, there are a number of factors, which includes a status check.
I'm sure you've seen something like this a lot
By default, through tools like these we can run through the tests.
We can test it automatically.
And now any additional tests, for example, can be run in a number of ways,
using CodeSandbox, Pika CI, etc.
Let me give you a brief description of the sandbox.
If CodeSandBox's CI is linked to the repository,
whenever you make a pull request, these comments are made automatically.
Then this pull request temporarily deploys the current state to the branch.
So this URL is created and with this you can install it
on any environment and test the parts you want to test manually
Or you can send it to a customer to see if this version works bettter.
Also, since CodeSandBox CI provides a Sandbox using this version
If you make a template in advance, you can easily test it.
And, if an issue occurs, you can add a commit to that very branch.
For example, say I simply want to change the wording of the changelog
Then you can edit the changelog and push it to the pull request.
Then, eventually, you can squash and merge the pull request.
When you click the squash and merge button like this, a new commit is added.
A message like 'chore: release v1.2.3' will be added.
So now the third process is Trigger.
A new commit will CI/CD and start the Trigger process
For example, you might have Circle CI or travis-CI.
Then the CI runs a script. What the script does is
npm run build, npm publish, and in some cases --tag beta, git tag v1.2.3
And it even git pushes.
Now, let’s review again
Update version, update changelog and git commit
And test, build, publish, tag, push
There is a whole process like this, this was part 1
This is part 2, this is part 3
So, this whole process has been broken down into three parts.
You don't have to wait around as much using this new process.
That's because, of the three parts, your computer only runs part 1
Part 2 is from GitHub and part 3 is from CI/CD service.
That means it takes less than a minute to run Part 1 on your computer.
So you are less likely to make mistakes.
Again, because in this whole process you only need to run Part 1
Part 2 and Part 3 are not your responsibility.
GitHub may suddenly go down or something like that
but unless that happens, there's no problem
reviewing on GitHub, and Circle CI won't stop working suddenly.
You will be able to separate those responsibilities, so you only need to run part 1 well.
The rest just follow a well-designed process.
That's why I tend to be less nervous using this process.
Also, if you run Part 2 which runs on GitHub, you can review it on your own
but you can also review with your colleagues or community members. Because of that,
you won't feel as stressed out about making mistakes.
You can also automate Part 1 and Part 3 entirely.
So I made a tool called Ship.js. This is a tool to automate Part 1 and Part 3.
You can run Part 1 using Ship.js
using the command 'shipjs preprare'
Part 2 is reviewed on GitHub, you can do it yourself or with a colleague
And Part 3 is the Ship.js trigger. This runs on CI/CD.
Ship.js has been deployd using Ship.js.
It's a little funny, but it actually only makes sense.
If Ship.js deploys without using Ship.js, that would be ironic.
So I’m going to show you a short video
At the time of updating from 0.20.0-beta.3 to the stable version 0.20.0
I have recorded the process
Let’s take a quick look
So there is this old version in the repository
But I will update this to 0.20.0.
I’m going to run the command from the command line, as you can see
The release is supposed to run the command shipjs prepare
Run yarn run release.
Then pull and update
Ship.js suggests making the next version a beta 4
But we say no because that's not it.
We enter the desired verison.
Then create a staging branch to update the version and changelog
That commit will make a pull request.
And it automatically opens the pull request on the browser.
So, if you look at it, lots of information is well summarized.
After you look at these and the review is done,
Squash and Merge, please.
But since it's a demo, I'll just ignore it and merge it right away.
You shouldn't do this in real life. You should wait for the approval then merge.
So now that we have a new commit to Circle CI,
A new task is running
Now, let's take a quick look at this task.
In this example, we're using Circle CI, and you can see the config here
We have a task workflow called 'Release if needed'
If you add it to the bramc called 'main', the task runs.
It's a task that installs and executes a command called "yarn shipjs trigger".
So after Circle CI prepares this and that,
runs "yarn shipjs trigger", then runs yarn build
then publishes to npm and then creates tags.
You can see it push to the github, too.
So if you refresh at npm, you'll see a new version of 0.20.0
This was deployed with the latest tag.
And if you go to GitHub, you can see a new version added to this release tab.
So if you run the command called 'shipjs setup'
You can use it easily because the CLI pops up to set up your repository.
You can also use GitHub Actions. You can see it introduces
Circle CI and other useful settings
or how the settings are set up
The documentations are well written so that you can try various settings
So far, so many contributors have helped us to develop Ship.js
Ship.js is not about tools
This is a story about a process
I came up with a new process to improve a process I found inconvenient
It’s the story of creating tools to support that process.
So I want you to take this idea and apply it to other libraries, languages, or other environments.
Just take it, but do let me know.
I just want to know what you will try out.
So, I'd like you to let me know and
I hope you can use this idea without bounds
and that your deployment process will be more enjoyable.
Thank you for listening.
You can find me on Twitter @eunjae_lee.
You can also find the Ship.js account under @ship_js. Thank you.